[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce concert de musique classique à la
Meurice de Trappes n'est pas un concert
comme les autres il est pédagogique 400
élèves majoritairement de quartiers
prioritaires composent le public ils
viennent de plaisir trap ou encore
Villepreux en tout 11 villes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines participent à
démocratiser la musique classique pour
la plupart de ses enfants c'est la
première fois qu'il voit jouer un
orchestre sur scène une séance comme
aujourd'hui c'est très intéressant parce
que les enfants découvrent la musique
live comme on dit en bon français la
musique vivante avec des vrais
instrumentistes de venteux et quel que
soit la qualité du disque la qualité des
interprètes à la télévision ça ne
remplacera jamais un concert vivant
l'oeuvre symphonique choisie le Concerto
pour clarinette de Mozart l'occasion
pour ses élèves de CE2 CM1 d'en
apprendre davantage sur l'histoire de ce
compositeur oui j'ai appris que Mozart
était
célèbre à 6 ans qu'il a composé un
concert
à 11 ans les élèves découvrent aussi les
instruments de l'orchestre on y trouve
la contrebasse la clarinette et une
trompette
le corps bien sûr le basson lui il avait
un son très grave
et par exemple la clarinette avait elle
peut elle pouvait faire le son grave et
aiguë les enjeux pour la pmsq et veiller
la curiosité des enfants et surtout leur
montrer que la musique classique est
partout même les Beatles ont repris la
musique classique il y a plein de choses
il y a des races aussi qui se font sur
la musique classique compris Beethoven
ou bac comme instru de base et ça fait
partie d'un cultures donc c'est très
important qu'ils aient cet apport
effectivement à l'école à l'école de la
République française et c'est vraiment
le moment où on fait groupe voilà et ça
c'est important parce que l'an dernier
moi j'avais un groupe classe qui était
pas toujours
très très soudée et ce projet
pédagogique ça nous a maintenu toute
l'année et ça nous a rassemblé et c'est
vrai que voilà on est devenu une équipe
le projet rassembleur prend encore plus
d'ampleur avec un autre événement
proposé par l'association l'opéra des
enfants en scène accompagné d'un
orchestre symphonique près de 350 élèves
de l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines s'initie aux
champs depuis le mois de décembre les
enfants travaillent avec la chef de
chœur des écoles sur un opéra détienne
Perruchon Dogora pour la première fois
le chef d'orchestre pierre calmelet va
alors rencontre pour leur donner des
conseils mais d'abord les élèves et
chauffent leur voix
oui oui
super
[Applaudissements]
le cours peut commencer la tâche est
complexe l'oeuvre musicale étant
dogorien une langue inventée par le
compositeur
[Musique]
puis chanter avec d'autres enfants
couper en même temps garder le rythme
toute la musique
au début ça paraît compliqué mais pas
après on s'y fait on y arrive de toute
façon c'est un projet incroyable que
nous fait vivre la pmsq c'est une
opportunité unique de vivre sur une
scène comme ça une scène nationale avec
un orchestre symphonique de chantait des
oeuvres je pense que personne au monde
ne peut rester insensible à ça
l'orchestre symphonique et la troupe de
jeunes chanteurs se produiront au
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le
samedi 1er juillet un spectacle vivant
qui promet d'être riche en émotion
[Musique]